we welcome to this video playing dr
imperial di imperial hmm Saudi Arabia no
Pakistan I'm sorry Saudi Arabia's eyes
grease green but the different him I'm
sorry alright so the groom felt let's
see I tried this crazy edge for line a
couple of times and people criticizing
me for playing such wacky stuff all
right I still do it Bishop to g4 hmm I
never saw that one against the smooth
isn't 95 good okay let's do that [ __ ]
strange the smooth Wow
interesting ok now let's grab it and
play you for this looks a really strange
for black giving up the center for
basically no compensation at least I
don't see it so what what what I am
doing now maybe h5 instead of yeah maybe
you can play h5 it still doesn't look
good but um it seems playable ok so d 4
is hanging how to how to react to that I
could play 5mm taking c4 it's not
possible it just takes d4 then I could
play f3 and send the night back but this
would weaken the dark squares really
enormously
there should be two is maybe a moose
okay let's do that Queen takes I take on
g4 2x context but I'm threatening Queen
c8 and to Bishop e3 look to 10 with
tempo yeah the third Queen default was
really bad I thought you should take
what the bishop okay maybe I didn't
judge this correctly it's possible of
course you should be three now or night
b5 is not great can do that however he's
got 95 with the temple
ya don't mind if she takes on two three
check check so still this stupid 95mm 52
melon let's go here this pattern
not quite sure what the ideas I just
when you t right now or not yeah I can I
could also move the Queen this is better
maybe Queenie to instead of taking here
taking yeah it's better right yeah it's
better he still needs to move the Queen
and at the end i have i can take and
play Queenie six this kind of idea queen
is six is the same the key point and now
just the edge porn or is there something
better he might might play Queen a for
something like this hmm it could also
double would be nice okay oh maybe me
and come on let's let's let's go for
Queen I for for King to g2 just
connecting the rooks I don't see how I
how I can keep the sea porn so we'll
just stroke you one Andrew p2
take a seven hour check this Queenie ate
meat if you go through PGA Tour
something that's Queen head with made
check yeah you need to go back please
enter go to c8 I guess hmm yeah hard to
assess I mean Bishop g4 and then taking
on c4 looked like complete insanity but
maybe it wasn't so terrible I mean I
well I didn't review the problem nah III
maybe III is better not allowing so much
counter that because I think in fact
after this okay I could think about f3
maybe f3 is the battles hi this it is I
overlooked a key point after this I can
I can also play maybe something like
that is it i'm not sure if it is so so
great maybe maybe just just to take and
play this position with Bishop here yeah
it's probably still good for what I
didn't like this this pawn formation ki
dat needs to take with the bishop which
is probably a quite unclear you know the
computer says black is basically winning
after that move I don't I don't believe
that let's sound check is this so bad
yeah why is this so bad I mean don't get
it 97 25 mm yeah maybe I'm a pawn down a
95 coming up but should be two probably
was bad but here this is so terrible I
don't know computer wants to play queen
bee three okay and now I play look do
you want check check yeah this was a big
mistake it should be four but he needs
to go here hmm yeah the computer has
very little enough for the solid concept
by white maybe it is just just bad i
mean i thought queen here maybe i just
gonna have six him yeah it's just bad
he's got also quincy to coming yeah
played this badly i was only saved by a
brother's blunder after that I think
white is basically basically winning
yeah that's not not much happening I
always can pick up the porn if I want
and he was nice enough to allow the mate
alright thanks for watching